you have you have records of so many
artists so many legends
but i feel like there's just something
about that pedigree
and your work ethic and what you've been
building that just
anybody who's paying attention has to
respect yeah like like even
like when the big artists come to the
bay they always grab me
bring me out like you know [ __ ] around
or whatever
um a lot of artists that um
i was talking before like before they
blew up we've
worked before right no no we're talking
about
you were telling me that you had an
opportunity to sign roddy richard back
in the day
yeah how many years ago was this because
roddy's been making music for
a while since he was a kid well this was
right before he took off
before he did whatever he did with nip
and meek and whatever like we had did
like
was this why he was still with bird yeah
okay okay
so you and bird almost connected
together on i'm riding a mutual friend
uh we came to the studio i think we did
like three records one night or whatever
and uh same thing with blue face too man
blue face we was in the lab
before he took off also out here like
like i'd be in tune to what's going on i
know i know bro
i've noticed yeah i i pay attention to
it
like you got to so why um why did you
end up not signing ronnie
um it wasn't just that i didn't i didn't
want to or nothing like that the
opportunity was brought to me
through a mutual friend or whatever we
work and then [ __ ] after that i just
went back to the bay
and we left it at that that's crazy we
stayed in contact
we still talk here in there me and faith
still talk here in there too but
i mean i feel like it's better for him
yeah um do you and and roddy have any
unreleased music together yeah we do
what's that studio red room
you guys cut some records there that's
what we did the songs there and so are
you going in blue face
dude that's crazy shout out to blue face
man he's a he's a funny dude without the
roddy richie and blue face man they both
doing anything they putting on for the
west man
no shade man i i love to see you know
people in this rap game win